it's no secret you know that we live in
a country filled with emotionally
fragile people and that's why we have
innovated a wide array of emotional
crutches and emotional supports
you can turn to a therapist or a
counselor psychiatrist a psychologist a
bottle of prescription pills
an emotional support animal
a therapeutic uh professional cuddler is
a thing now too
and then there's also this New York the
New York Post reports on one of the
latest examples
it says can't bear to be alone this
holiday season a human-sized emotional
support bear might be the perfect gift
for you the loving bear puffy is the
shape and size of a male human body but
has the head of a teddy bear
just look at that thing there it is
puffy is a very personal product
invented by an ordinary woman who is
afraid of being alone the company said
uh the five foot seven inch oversized
plush bear weighing just seven pounds is
160 and replaces the need for the
physical presence of a person in various
moments and situations of everyday life
especially during long long nights so
this this lonely woman apparently she
couldn't make do with cats and so she
invented this and it's put on sale for
160 this is indeed a wonderful gift for
the serial killer in your life if you
want to help the creepy bastard in your
life become even creepier then this is a
good gift for them
I mean I don't know you well I mentioned
those those professional cuddling
Services people hire actual humans to
cuddle them
and that seems even worse than this so
maybe maybe this this could be a good
way to wean somebody off of that
if they're addicted to the professional
cuddling services or maybe it's the
other way around what's worse the higher
professional cuddler
or to buy a six foot tall human eye
humanoid teddy bear to cuddle with
which would make you more ashamed if you
were the parent of an adult child
engaging in this activity it's
impossible to say
what I will say on a slightly more
serious note is that there is
a loneliness epidemic in this country
people are very lonely
they're alone they're they're desperate
for some kind of human contact
even if they have to pay for it or
settle for a giant teddy bear instead
we have tried to make people in this
culture into these kind of autonomous
entities telling them that they they
don't need marriage they don't need
families they don't need anyone as long
as you have the cold bureaucratic
Embrace of the state then you'll be fine
but it turns out that doesn't work
it doesn't satiate the longing of the
human heart
and that's what leads to this
then again I have no room to talk I am
the guy with the life-size stuffed
walrus so no that isn't for cuddling
that's strictly for decor
unless I have a really bad day which
case all bets are off
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you